what's up welcome daddy likes the show
my mic pack is stabbing me
whatever the worst thing are some of the
videos that I saw this week that I
thought were really amazing now Improv
Everywhere it's probably one of my
favorite YouTube channels they pulled
this Olympic torch prank where they had
somebody with an Olympic torch trying to
find people on the street who would
carry the torch and make it seem like
they actually made it to the finish line
I love these types of videos because it
really shows how much fun you can have
with people but I always feel so bad
like I could never do these types of
videos because I would feel terrible I'd
feel like an awful person like I'm so
sorry that I just made a fool of you
moving on to things that are not the
Olympics cute animals that's something
that everyone can relate to and if you
can't relate to it you need to just go
somewhere else
one of my favorite morgues is shoveling
like I just think it's really funny to
just use it in ways that you wouldn't
normally use it like hey I'm gonna take
this cake and shovel it into my face if
you can think of something is better
than having a cute puppy shovel snow
good leave me a comment I dare you to
challenge me a video this week that I'm
a bit biased because I make a cameo in
George Takei yes George freaking 2k has
a show here on YouTube called Takei's
take and I got a chance to go on his
show chat with him eat with him vlog
with him that episode is now live so you
can go check it out on their YouTube
channel I'll leave an annotation and put
a link in the description where you guys
can go and watch it make sure you leave
a comment on that video and say that I
sent you to see it I think I had another
video to show you and I don't remember a
hold on let me look yes yes oh god I
can't believe I forgot this one turns
you every single one of you guys has
sent me this video credits for this
video what somebody's flying in a plane
they drop a GoPro it falls into a pigpen
all the way down into the Pigpen someone
finds said GoPro and posts the footage
many months later I'm a feeling this is
just some sort of crafty commercial it
may have already come out with some
crafty commercial I don't care either
bike it's a cool video if it was an ad
you know what doesn't matter I love
GoPro I have a GoPro not sponsored just
love this week was absolutely a great
week for gaming you guys missed it the
titanfall beta was out so I've been
playing this game all week and it's been
so much fun it's kind of like a mix
between halo meets Call of Duty meets
just awesomeness I don't have so much
fun playing it my favorite part is you
can do this crazy parkour and just jump
off of walls and stick to the wall and
just the game actually comes out on
March 11th so I can promise you actually
I will be at a tool concert but after
that you know I'll be also a game that
many of you guys are looking forward to
Donkey Kong Country tropical freeze is
out I'm not a huge Donkey Kong fan but I
think it'll be an awesome game I'm
probably gonna be trying to complete
Legos to 100% so I may have my hands a
little full let me know what games you
guys are most looking forward to I'm
looking forward to obviously titanfall
Mario Kart which is out in May I've had
were suppose to be on April but I
believe it's in May and of course
destiny for Xbox one moving right on to
beauty and style
I don't really show you oh let me find
something the first thing I actually
bought this in Canada this is a
foundation stick pretty sweet it's so
good that I end up just using it as a
concealer or just kind of covering up
stuff throwing on some powder and
running out the door it is how we do is
Francesca actually gave me this and it
is one of my focus focus you Pig it is
NYX butter gloss I'm not wearing it
currently but no no you've got a
sometimes a little precise it's all I've
got for you for this episode who I J
likes if you guys have any suggestions
for future episodes you know where to
find me Twitter Instagram everywhere as
iJustine to leave me a comment you can
tweet me you can do all of those things
to me
and I will see you in the next video so
that's it ie
you